what it's like being part of what I feel
and I think a lot of people feel is uh
since 1980.
it's rather great really when you when I
hear you say that I mean the show is
incredible
listen I think you know Tony's vision
and and the team we collated and the
story he is telling are just a huge
passion for everybody involved and the
real inspiration and and it is a real
pleasure and joy to be part of this
journey and a gift to have found such an
extraordinary response and loving your
costumes
um yeah no it's it's just a great
journey and Simon has dedicated five
years of her life to this project so and
I'm the most incredible job
thank you
uh Andy when did you real I mean people
love your character on this series
when did you realize that uh this was
going to be something special
oh look I mean when
pretty much when I first talked to Tony
about getting involved in it I mean he's
so he was so passionate about it I mean
I was such a massive fan of Rogue one it
was such a great film and you know take
having having had the opportunity to
have seen Star Wars from a particular
perspective
um on the dark side and then uh and then
and then actually when I was approached
I was I was quite trepidatious because I
was thinking you know there are so many
snoke theories over the years that I'd
had to duck and dive in a void and kind
of and then I just thought oh no this is
going to be nightmare because people are
going to think keynote lawyers somehow
associated with with you know smoke and
I'm gonna have to talk around the houses
and get you know but but but but then
when he he explained to me what he was
doing and when uh you know and and the
character and
and and what of course with every single
character in Andor there is such depth
and humanity and they're flawed or
they're you know and and the way that
Cassian weaves his way through this this
incredible heroic journey through you
know kind of
experiencing all of these extraordinary
characters but when but wait the way
Tony explained the the the the arc that
I was going to be involved in you know I
just instantly had an enormous respect
for I mean I've you know I've always
respected him as a writer director uh
but but just
his Integrity in terms of being
authentic and knowing what he wants to
say and to use this platform and to use
this world and and universe to say such
important things about The Human
Condition uh it was it to me it's it
really just took me in and it's exactly
the sort of filmmaking or storytelling
that I like to be involved in well the
thing that like I was really you know I
was rewatching episode 8 10 with
everyone in the audience and I just you
forget that this is a TV show because
the production design the writing every
aspect of this series is just on another
level so can you both talk a little bit
about that like what's it like on set
seeing what these brilliant crew people
are bringing to life and obviously the
incredible writing
I I think the whole process of how we
can realize it and bring Tony's Vision
to the screen really started in the
writer's room where our production
designer is already part of it and even
and you know the early early stages and
for the many challenges to also kind of
feed through right from the start what
may be possible what isn't what
Solutions we could you know find in
order to bring that Vision to the screen
and and it is it's a whole lot of
conversations and uh and and you know
many many you know kind of meetings and
details to be discussed about the
truthfulness and if you're creating a
Star Wars prison what does it look like
how can it be fresh it's kind of a real
challenge to embark on on anything it
was prison there have been so many
iterations and amazing Stories be told
and And yet when Tony realized that he
needed Cassian to be locked up it was a
real challenge right right from the
start to think how did we go about it
how can we be fresh and it was little
things that started off we didn't want
it to be darkened and and dingy and we
thought well if it's a Star Wars
facility it should be shiny and clean
and the opposite and then we came to
maybe there is no bars anywhere maybe
you don't need staff and and it was just
an extraordinary Whirlwind with Tony and
and Dan and Bowen in a room and and to
really kind of Riff what is the basis
and and you know if he came to an
electric floor and and the whole story
and reality of how it works and what it
does that then also enables Tony to
write how you could stage a rebellion
within and how you know Cassian finding
himself locked up there could have seen
enough to begin to get the kernels of
getting out of there and how do you you
know facilitate communication prisons
always have communications and yet how
difficult visit when you find yourself
in a world where you have super
regimented and can't mingle and and you
know and all these many many discussions
and thoughts kind of led us to what it
came to and and and then you also know
what you have to build and look you
never have enough money to do anything
you want to do and and yet you have to
find a way and so you would be probably
surprised how little we built in the end
and and you know and how we cleverly
used and reused and you know what we had
in order to create a world that is
ultimately huge and of course CG
extensions you know help us a lot but
you know also have to be at a minimum
you know so yeah it was quite an
extraordinary journey and and Michael
Wilkinson creating the costumes what
does a what does the Star Wars prison
uniform look like
um
wow prison Couture was not something he
you know he imagined he would be good at
um and yeah so it has been an
extraordinary complex much shorter
journey and God I'm thrilled that I
think we I think we got there and got it
right
Andy I'm I'm curious I'm just gonna ask
you uh did they tell you when you were
filming what you guys were building or
did you did they leave that alone and
say just watch the show I actually
worked it out because my son had the
star the the uh you know the Death Star
Lego
um
and I saw the pieces and I thought all
right okay I get it
nobody was told no it was gonna say so
you had no idea until you actually put
it together on your own
did it get spread like a rumor like uh
yeah it was all hand signaled over to it
you know
he started to you know communicating
with each other what do you think's
being made you know I haven't got a clue
uh a lot of this audience knows how the
sausage is made and I'm curious for both
of you what do you think might surprise
and or fans to learn about the actual
making of Andor
question
I don't know wow uh well you know I I I
have to say just talking about the pre
you know going to the prison you know um
we every time so there were obviously
there were a lot of supporting artists
in the in the prison setup and uh there
was there was nowhere to there was
nowhere to hide on that set everything
there's it's really extraordinary
because you're talking about you know
prisons being you know you think of them
as dark dingy places and so on and so
forth you know this was this was wide
open bright white glaring lights metal
underneath your feet wearing paper no
shoes no shoes paper uniform and that
was the that was a strange thing was
Finding Your sliders after every single
scene the 50 50 people trying to get
find their own pairs of Sliders to get
back in to walk to walk back to uh
sometimes a hundred so yeah yeah exactly
I also I think I think one thing that is
probably hard to imagine even now but
you know this wonderful tunnel see
corridors to say you know that you know
we're connecting us over the sleeping
pots are into Factory floor in a it was
just a very long set elevated and he you
had to close the doors and post ends and
when we were filming in there there were
a hundred people and plus crew in it at
a time where we are wearing masks and
covert was very much amongst us and felt
over slightly counter-intuitive but
you'll be pleased that nothing ever
happened to anyone and that was
remarkable it was extraordinary actually
like you say I mean those those they
were literally like covered test tubes
that we were kind of you know living in
for for all together a very close
proximity there was nowhere to hide that
was the thing that that those sets did
something so strange to your heads
because it was like normally normally
you know when you're filming you find a
little place to go and sit and you've
got your own you know you've got your
stash of stuff then you you know
whatever you've got your bits and pieces
but it just wasn't like that on this set
it was so
desensitizing and just that being
barefooted all the time and you know
those uniforms they just they it really
all it did all help for the drama but
got it mucked you around and head around
you know it really really got inside you
and I think nobody would have any idea
how many conversations we had about you
know the lift taking you down from the
intake down to the floor I think I don't
mean I mean more than 50 and so many
people involved and the mechanics of it
and what it had to deliver and what it
had to achieve and yes it had to be
practical and sfx and it was a lot of
thought went into it and and you know
all worth it because when we came to
film it in crazy days or so
um you know I love the moment when you
start charging
um it was really quite profound it's you
know it really came together it was a
very fun memories of the time I I still
don't understand it you guys did it
because basically every three episodes
was like a new pilot you know like new
stuff and I I mean I just can only say
you know uh thank you so many times
because it's so you know incredible but
I want to ask you and then uh you've
answered this I know at least 50 times
maybe a hundred but obviously we never
see Kino die and now that you've you've
spent a decent amount of time with Tony
have you guys actually had any
conversations about like the what ifs
what could be and have you been filming
anything on season two
[Laughter]
well now that would be telling but
um you know there is a see there is a
scene of keynote on his own
practicing the cruel and the
breaststroke in his cell
imagining how he could know I have no
idea what's going on no idea no idea no
idea no not at all well I'm gonna one of
the things I think it's such a beautiful
scene watching when he says I can't swim
and obviously it's the culmination of
everything so talk a little bit about
filming that scene delivering that line
and where they're alt versions where you
were saying it differently talk a little
bit you know if you don't mind sure I
mean that that act that scene actually
was the very very last day of the of the
shoot of the whole thing of all of the
Season
literally wrapped after you know that
literally people were diving jumping off
and then it was just like and that's it
rap and we're able to go home and it was
but it so it was a big day anyway uh but
what was what was great was Toby Haynes
the director who did such an incredible
job of this Arc and and and uh you know
of the of these episodes
um he really did allow he really was
interested in in putting Nuance of
performance and he he he he we tried oh
I I did that scene
um many many different ways uh just in a
trying to explore what it is like to
look he was a character that that that
um you know had sort of kind of lost
himself he I always imagined that he was
prior to being incarcerated someone who
had great heart who was in fact probably
someone who would have stood up for his
fellow workers would have been a shop
steward or a union rep who was strong a
fire brand passionate cared about other
people and then completely once he was
incarcerated probably because he was
very good at galvanizing people and the
Empire would have been threatened by
someone like that you know once he's
incarcerated completely loses his
um you know he just wants to get through
his sentence and get out and actually
becomes very very uh hard and and and
bitter and just just doesn't want to
make any ripples just get through the
situation and
um so so when it when it when of course
Cassian arrives and the whole story
unfolds and the reality is that no one's
gonna get out and
then it's reignited this this whole
thing of being a once again being able
to care for your fellow you know your
fellow inmates and and actually really
sort of connect reconnect with a version
of yourself that you've never thought
you'd find again so so we so went
through all of that and then the day
comes where you get to to and I knew
this obviously I knew what was going to
happen but but there are so many
different ways of playing that moment
and we explored a kind of you know an
anger we explored a kind of resignation
we explored a kind of gallows humor kind
of you know we we tried lots of
different variations and I think I mean
the one that Toby finally put in the cut
and and is the one that you saw was was
one of uh was of acceptance and a kind
of and I I was really glad I was
actually really glad that that was the
the the version that made it because
because he was again it was sort of like
this the it was a perfect end to the
journey of that character that that
acceptance just a quick question about
acting
um how are you like the night before
you're filming something like that are
you practicing those lines at home are
you in your head about it and how much
are you sort of thinking about it in the
moment you know right before you're
walking to set well obviously look I
mean there are lots of actors approach
things in different ways and everybody
has their own process I
um the the big kind of the the the build
up to the to the escape and and the uh
the speech that he makes the the one way
out you know it was I that that was
um very nerve-wracking because those
speeches can go horribly horribly wrong
if if you don't if you if you're not in
the moment and you're actually feeling
it and if you overthink things and you
prescribe things too much you you can
really come across as as if it's too
premeditated then because you've worked
hard on you know you've got to you've
got to know it so well that you can
throw it away and be in the moment and
that's that's the thing and so and
that's that's as an actor I think is
what you know you do all you do a lot of
preparation you do a lot of backstory
building you do a lot of kind of working
out who this person is physicality voice
all that kind of stuff and then you kind
of have to throw it away and Trust the
moment because because the great things
happen
in the moment and the things that you're
not prepared for and you have to be open
to that so so I mean uh
I mean I was really really scared the
day that I had to do the big kind of
speech and and actually so was Kino Loy
so it sort of worked out so when when
when when when Diego you know says oh
sorry when uh Cassian says you know is
that all you got you know it was just
like every time we did that I was just
like I hope I can get through this I
hope you know and and so it it it sort
of felt very it felt very real and and
and and and and present and in the
moment because it was because there was
you know find you know Kino finding his
Mojo again was was it was a genuine sort
of thing you just you don't know as an
actor you don't know whether you're
going to do it you don't know whether
you're going to deliver you hope you're
going to deliver but there's no
guarantee and sometimes you don't so
it's like it's always scary uh because
Tony's not here I'm gonna ask you this
question I love Stalin there's a few
monologues in and or that are
unbelievable in an episode 10 there's
the stellen monologue uh and so talk a
little bit about how does that is it the
writer is it Beau who's writing the
episode writing that thing how is like
talk a little bit how these things come
together uh in pre-production I mean it
really was a writing thing and I think
and you know I mean Tony's in a show
generally and I think as he doesn't shy
away from it Beau doesn't shy away from
it and his writing Partners don't you
know that its speeches are sometimes
something that is really poignant and
right and and I think it's the most
extraordinary piece of writing for
stellen's speech and the most the most
truthful and important thing for his
character at that moment to to to learn
you know the truth and and to hear him
give things away when he is you know
ultimately the Puppeteer who very
cleverly pulls the strings behind closed
doors and you actually know very little
about him initially just that you know
he can he has two personalities and you
know and a very good cover story that he
lives that aids his course and I think
picking that moment uh to to give him
such a profound speech that is so human
and so deep I mean it was electric
deferment it was I'm sure scary for
stellen too to prepare for it but but
also you know I just know what Joy he
felt when he read it and how thrilled he
was to be giving something that is such
an you know extraordinary opportunity
for you know some extraordinary
performance so yeah it's it's just
really lovely that Andor of the show
makes that possible but a lot of other
shows shy away from you think about
Marva and her eulogy you know it just
you know it really gives characters you
know there's a chance to very truthfully
and and kind of naturally come to a
place where they have something rather
profound to give away and share I
definitely have to ask you I see
obviously there's people dressed up in
the prison outfit uh did you take your
prison outfit home or were you like I'm
burning this the second we rap oh I use
them as my pajamas now I mean
yeah
uh no I didn't take my costume home
um because you wouldn't have wanted to
go anywhere near our costumes by the end
of the shoot I have to tell you they
were not in uh you know they you could
smell people a mile off it was like not
good what is it like for you though
because uh you were at Star Wars
celebration and I saw there were so many
people cosplaying uh in costume what is
what is it like being a part of
something would which strikes such a
nerve with so many people and they want
to be a part of it I mean I first sort
of got wind of the the the that this was
sort of a thing gonna be a thing
um in Tokyo at the Tokyo Comic-Con
actually just before Christmas and I you
know I was meeting lots of people and
then suddenly people coming up dressed
as you are magnificently and and wanting
to go on program and wanting to you know
you know and want to chant one way out
and and it it was like what the wherever
so someone told you about this was that
you know it's just like it was it was I
don't know and I think and I kind of
have thought about this and it's like
you know it's it's I think when you have
um you know we're living in a world now
where where it's very very where there's
so much censorship where there is so
much uh oppression and people feel
squashed in so many ways not just kind
of politically squashed but but but
ideologically and culturally and you
know people feel really
you know through coming out of covid
through or through all the the the the
stuff that's going on in the world at
the moment you know people feel
oppressed I think and so I think that is
sort of partially what Tony Tony's
Tony's a great allegorical writer he's
not writing for right now but because as
he would say you know the you know this
is this is if he was writing this a
hundred years ago he'd be writing the
same thing it's not it's not just about
about the world that we live in today
there's a universal truth in how he
writes and he was writing about an
anti-fashion he was right he was talking
yesterday about this he was writing an
anti-fascist piece that's what this is
about and so and I think that that that
that the kind of the release of that is
what people are tapping into and
enjoying and and and and finding you
know the excitement and energy from
[Applause]
um this is a producer question do you
think we're going to get an Andor behind
the scenes dock for season one on Disney
Plus
I really don't know but you know let me
find out that's Marshall Marshall
do you know
do you do is it a no or you don't know
I have no idea oh there we go sorry uh
I'd really love it if you would pass up
the food chain that a lot of people
would like to watch whatever you want to
surpass on the message apps a new thing
actually uh you should you should
mention uh and I'm not sure how many of
you heard but they're going to be in the
middle of the month I think they're
going to release the scripts online for
people to read yes Tony announced it
yesterday you know the the final script
and and that will be released online
with together with some concept art you
know to to Really you know kind of
combine that set information and and I
know the ulr wasn't up yet and and Tony
couldn't remember and so but yes it is
happening and I believe it is imminent
and you know I yeah I think anybody who
is a fan I think reading Tony's words
you know not only you know and to see
what the basis was of what you know we
we created will be a really exciting
Journey I'm very thrilled that has
happening for each of you uh there's
always people behind the scenes that
don't get enough credit in the creation
of something like this so for each of
you who is an unsung hero that you want
to shine a light on that really helped
you with Andor for me there is so many I
mean and as you know when you're
producing anything without your
production team and my you know this I
don't know my I could name them all now
my you know the producers Network
alongside me and the entire team but I
think it is also really our entire crew
we have a very large team of very
dedicated and very talented people that
are hugely inspired by Tony's in our
vision and to show that we are doing it
is filmmaking is if team effort
filmmaking is is it's all about a whole
bunch of people coming together and
bringing something that kind of often
exceeds Tony the expectations and and
does you know create something very
magic and it is the entire team we are
blessed with our Pilgrim family and I
love them all and thank them forever and
without them none of us would be shining
and sitting here and you wouldn't be
enjoying the show that you know I'm so
thrilled you are enjoying
is there someone you want to shine a
light on oh no I mean look I just echo
echo everything in Center saying you
know it's it is an immense team effort
and there you you feel when you're on a
show that you know when you feel the
energy of the crew behind you all the
time kind of there for you at every
single moment it's because they are they
are transported by by the material and
the passion of the filmmakers and so on
and so forth but but everyone
collectively feels that energy and so so
I mean I can't single anyone out in
particular but because because it's it's
a massive organism that that thrives on
on everybody bringing 150 every day to
make to make something work and and that
and that energy is is when you when it's
on a show that you know and you do feel
it when you're on a show that feels
special you you you because and it comes
from it comes from the authenticity of
the storytelling that's where it comes
from because you feel like you're making
something that actually is important and
and to be able to speak about important
things in in a Star Wars universe is
like it's just Joy it's just like it
doesn't get any better you that you can
that you can you can actually
communicate important ideas in a in a
genre which you know many people who
don't get it or don't understand it
would ridicule but actually you know
we're all part of you know you you're
you're contracted to it you know with
the actors the the producers that but
the crew they you know they keep they're
the they're they're the engine room of
the whole thing you know and it's it's
it's
um it is it is I think it is about about
you knowing that you're saying something
that has has real value that people are
gonna love you know but as we are
shining the light and the crew I really
also have to say we have the most
extraordinary ensemble cast I mean we
had 175 or 79 mind speaking parts we had
you know huge numbers of crowd and every
single pharyxian in the end after a very
long journey in a really when when the
riot came they were fighting
asphalicians for their first survival it
is an extraordinary journey and and
every person that stepped in front of
the camera really was just a joy and and
only when that all comes together again
like there's a team when you're making
it you know and preparing it in order to
turn over it is you know every single
element has to work together to be able
to create something that feels real and
authentic and it's something that you
know you can dive into and and you know
immerse yourself into and enjoy as a
producer I'm so curious this show seemed
like it was endless challenges like
there was nothing easy about the making
of Andor so what what do you think was
like level 10 out of 10 in terms of
trying to pull it off with your budget
and schedule god is there anything that
is in level 10 or Beyond I mean
hovert of course when we you know added
the extra Dimension we had to stop 11
weeks out from filming and like
everybody else in the world and fight to
come back out of the door because not so
easy when you are a big show with a lot
of people involved and a huge cast and
huge crowds and to find a safe way that
was an added
um a little conundrum but I don't know
about that time it become a reason Detra
to to that we kind of felt we had to do
this come what may and we shall Prevail
and that Spirit was also a real Joy but
I think that added you know an extra
bonus but yes there's nothing easy about
shows that uh have this scale and when
you produce for the small screen you
always have to
you know cut out all the waste and have
extra focus and and achieve more within
a day in order to bring these values to
screen and it is a daily challenge and
but also an exciting one another now
it's you know it's something that we
chose to do and I'm I'm I'm glad I did
every day yeah I I really don't know how
you do it like the I really don't know
for real but I want to one day go into
therapy and try to work that's true
uh I want to see if anyone has any
questions out here and I do see some
hands where is Marshall there he is uh
Marshall do you want to pick some people
hey Andy
I had a question for you I feel like all
of us in our head Canon uh head Canon
you know that's what we make up because
we love your characters so much One Way
Out Stephen I think tried to ask you
about the fate of your character but in
your own head Canon the story that
you've made up what happened to him did
he jump off did he get pushed off did he
realize he actually knew how to swim
what happened and he tell us in your
head please oh he's he's in my mind I
always have this picture of him
you know sitting in his cell very
quietly trying to trying to trying to
practice swim strokes and you know
Harmony I really am joking but but no I
think I think look he would have he
would have found the other survivors and
and other people that weren't able to
make it out because of course there are
also a lot of injured people a lot of
people who who weren't able to to make
the jump you know so I think he would
have stayed and he would have galvanized
them he would have brought them together
they would have found a way of surviving
until you know now now that that they've
realized that there weren't that many
gods
overseeing them
um they would have the the power shift
would have been would have been there
and you know he would he would have been
able to to at least create some kind of
semblance of a society or a small
Society however many survivors there
were you know and until until help was
coming so I think that's I think that's
probably what what uh where he would
have gone I just have to ask when you
were filming this show did you have any
idea how many people were going to be
asking like begging for this character
to survive no but not not at all but I
tell you what that some of the Comic
Cons I've I've been to have there's been
amazing t-shirts with Kino Loy swimming
Society kind of you know uh
um you know it's all manner of of memes
of you know Kino with a with a with a
life preserve around is what you know
it's like it's quite incredible yeah how
that has touched people I mean what are
you are you all afraid of swimming or
something I mean you know
yeah
it's incredible hi I'm Laura I'm curious
what you imagined the precursor to your
story how did you end up in prison and
how did you get into character when you
ended up going you know on set each day
no I mean I I I I think I mentioned
earlier you know the the idea that this
this was a guy who was quite a political
figure who who was very strong-willed
had a family and was a family of man but
also was it was you know would go out on
strike or would uh stand up for fellow
workers rights and the Very fact that he
is a Firebrand and and is able to you
know mobilize people and and inspire
people to to do the right thing you know
would have would have seemed a threat to
to the Empire which is which is kind of
in my mind we you know and actually and
actually I I I based him very closely on
my brother-in-law who who sadly's past
but he he who was who was that person
who actually who actually
um was a very very Ardent uh kind of
socialist and and was often in in uh you
know it was it was was on political kind
of
um you know he was often on strikes and
and it was adamant about about work
equality and workers rights and I think
I think that that for me was was I
wanted him to to have that Integrity
really and and then have that Stripped
Away From Him only to to be able to find
it again hello I got a question for uh
the two of you uh you you mentioned
earlier that uh you had to do a prison
spin on Star Wars and I'm just curious
if there's any movies or or
entertainment that you watched like
Shawshank Redemption you know Escape
from Alcatraz that brought any sort of
inspiration to how the characters would
deal with the situation I think any
there's so many really quite profound
prison movies that one has seen and
they're all give you a lot of food for
thought and and have you know given all
kinds of wonderful depictions of of you
know inmates within and to situations
and a lot of political and difficult
situations so I think all of that makes
you think and and all of that emotional
truth that you know that will exist
within a facility where a whole lot of
people find themselves locked up you
know certainly were important to to to
embrace and and you know Tony
storytelling but anyway because we are
following you know characters through
their journey and what this
incarceration does to them and uh but
you know it's all an inspiration and yet
it was also always sitting how how can
we be emotionally truthful and also
truthful for how it functions and works
within that world and and yet you know
create our own version that that you
know becomes a believable entity in now
in in you know for Star Wars and we
ended up being Elvis what you saw on
screen
um I've I've filmed in a number of uh
prisons over the years
um there are two that really were were
outstanding one was in in Russia I was
in Russia filming just after the wall
came down in the 90s in 1990 I was doing
a series out in Saint Petersburg and
there was a Roman prison that was built
for uh I think it was it was built for
280 prisoners or something like that and
there were nearly 3 000 prisoners in in
this place and the cells were literally
about six foot square and they had about
30 people in each cell and there was a
hierarchy in in each cell where some
people were allowed to stand some people
could sit on the bed some people could
sit on the lower beds and most people
had to sit on the floor and it was and
then they were all brought out uh they
were doing sort of um blood tests on
them and they pulled every single one of
them out and they went along the line
with using the same needle and jabbed
each arm you know just went along the
line and it was just like I've never
seen I have never really seen Humanity
uh the abuse of kind of a power and
these people were these people were
hadn't been these these this is a Roman
prison so they hadn't actually been
charged with anything and there were a
lot of them were in there for years when
they were without without actually being
charged so so and then the other place
was San Quentin prison when I was
filming Venom and uh uh directing Let
There Be Carnage and we shot in San
Quentin and that was that was an
extraordinary place too and again lots
of lifers living there who have come to
terms with the fact that they're never
going to leave and sort of talking to
people and
so so there were lots of lots of
inspiration for for for you know for for
this show and I think I think one of the
brilliant design decisions as as Anna
was saying was was the was not having
any bars
uh you know so so that it gives and and
and and it being bright and white and
really sort of threatening but in a
different way so you're there's a
claustrophobia being uh you know and and
I think that's it's sort of it really
messes with your with your head because
you do think of Prisons as dark dank
kind of places with bars and so on
um but but it was but yeah no I carried
those I carried those images with me
when I was when I was when we were on
the shoot and uh and just how people get
through those situations and also
um
do you you know that the Memphis Three
Story you know the west of Memphis the
the the Memphis Three Story well I I met
uh Damien who was one of the three who
was wrongly accused of uh you know
Murder and was in prison for 18 years
and actually when we were filming The
Hobbit in New Zealand
um and Peter Jackson had made the west
of Memphis documentary he Damien came
out of prison whilst it was the
documentary was actually being made he
was he actually came out and came and
stayed with us down in New Zealand he he
could barely see he'd only been used to
um looking like at a six foot cell he
was in isolation a complete isolation
for 18 years and and he couldn't his
eyes were just adjusting to the light
and
um he'd never seen a DVD he'd never seen
didn't know what Sushi was he didn't
know what you know all these kind of
things we take for granted he'd come out
and this world had kind of completely
changed and so all of these things were
sort of buzzing around my head when we
were kind of drawing drawing
Inspirations for um for for being in on
nakina Vive anyway hello
um I was wondering because in the show
we see Cassian askino if he ever thought
about escaping before
and I'm curious did Kino before meeting
Cassian ever think about it or was he
just complacent with being a cog in the
wheel no he was absolutely never he
wouldn't ever have dreamed about it
because he just wanted to keep his head
down not cause any ripples just through
his time and get out and that and they
shut down he was like emotionally shut
down hey what makes you love acting
okay lightning round
knowing knowing okay knowing why I'm an
actor and that that by by which I mean I
I love storytelling and I love
um going out researching coming back and
sharing my findings with an audience
that's amazing
that is fantastic this side uh yeah can
each of you share like an outtake or a
funny moment from set I mean with such
heavy material that you were working
with I assume there's still some
bloopers
have they released Andor bloopers no we
haven't I'm assuming you have a Sizzle
reel
no there is none actually
um I don't know maybe we were not funny
enough but
um no there was just there were a lot of
hilarious moments but you know they're
generally mishaps and and so we just try
to protect us from themselves from those
but oh God I don't know I can't I can't
name one of them prison related either
no no sorry I'm failing you
I I only only that you would not have
wanted to be after lunch you wouldn't
have wanted to be in in one of those
test tubes
with a hundred people you know kind of
yeah releasing uh
not a good situation
yeah one way out yeah
hey this is Randy uh just curious about
uh building the physicality of character
and like I know you've done a lot of
voices in your career was there ever the
thought of doing a voice for this
character stuff like that
well yeah I mean you know whenever you
create a character it's part of the
building of the character is is is the
psychological makeup of the character
which then informs everything to do with
the physicality and voice it's all it's
all bound up with that you know where
you where a character carries tension
pain uh where your centers of your
energy are where you lead from where you
know your head did you lead from the
head are you from the heart are you for
you know you you make up in a set of
assumptions for each character that you
play
again I'm going to shorten this I'm not
going to
hey Andy um who's your fan of yours
since Laura drinks movies
um actually I was planning to watch
Ender already but as soon as I heard you
are in the show then I just started to
watch it so what's your favorite Star
Wars movie and which character would you
like to be from the movies if you had
another opportunity except Kino and
Snook
[Laughter]
[Applause]
laughs
uh
hi a question for Sana um what led to
the decision to shoot
um on location rather than using the
volume
I think we were always about that I mean
Tony's writing doesn't lend itself to to
fit into a volume ultimately it's an
extraordinary new technology and and
really a wonderful thing to exist but
you know his whole storytelling was
really never particularly catered to it
and when we went into this we always
said we will shoot as much in camera and
only extend what we need that comes with
um you know with the territory of Star
Wars the effects will be part of it but
you know to try and and shoot the
old-fashioned way as much in camera as
possible before we get to the next
question I'm just going to say that who
was anyone at Star Wars celebration
well there we go uh so it did anybody
else see the acolyte footage
so that was also it's not on the volume
it's it's a shot on location and it
really just like Android had so much the
the Practical locations it is I mean
combining State bills and location and
Backlot work really became the DNA of
our show sorry for interrupting her
um what was the prison food supposed to
be
well it wasn't it was It was supposed to
have flavor but I never tasted the
flavor I I didn't experience the flavor
it it all tasted pretty bland to me
the food only got flavor when the team
did well and
[Applause]
hi can you talk a little bit about the
relationship between
um Cassian and Kino and what moment it
made him snap back into trying to fight
yeah I mean I you know the the thing is
Cassian doesn't give up you know Cassian
is uh is is is a force you know and he
is always
he's always observing he's very he's so
observant and kind of particular and
he's he thinks steps ahead
um kilo was is such a uh you know would
have been pulling in the other direction
so so strongly but it's it is that
moment I think I think once he saw Olaf
who was the the character that that part
you know that passes
um that around that time that that would
have been a moment where cassium would
have seen
his response
and and just seeing the crack in in uh
you know in Kino's character and
realizing that there was a grain of
humanity left and and and knowing that
he was able to Galvanize people that's
that that I mean I think for me that
that was the point you know and then of
course that episode ends with you know
never more than 12. so so that it was it
was it's definitely at that moment
yeah Andy any interest in directing on
season two
no
I haven't been asked yet actually
you're brought up we should asterisks
Andy are you currently directing
something
I am actually I'm directing Animal Farm
by George Orwell another
[Applause]
um
another another
um you know piece of Storytelling about
tyranny and um and actually gosh there
are some great similarities uh in this
in this story to uh to and or really I
mean yeah it's it's a brilliant book
sadly it's you know everlastingly
relevant um as as this story is too uh
and and we've got a great cast which
hasn't been announced yet so I can't
tell you but surely will and it'll be
ready uh to for to be for your viewing
pleasure and we've got about another
year to go so uh yeah thank you Stephen
and thank you both for coming tonight
it's really really appreciated
as both great creative contributors to
TV and to movies and to the best
characters who've Ever Walked on four
legs uh
was there a time that you felt your
creativity was fragile or something that
you could only access through certain
ritual or certain time of day and uh if
so how was that changed I I I started
Life as a theater actor well yeah I I
started life as an actor in the theater
and I did lots and lots of theater and I
adored it and felt it really connected
with you know you commun you communicate
with an audience in a very profound way
um I I had an accident on stage when
um I was playing Iago in Othello the
Royal exchange theater in Manchester and
I I got I I got put in there's a there's
a scene a very intense scene in the
middle of the play where Othello really
goes for Iago and and and the guy who's
playing I thought it pulled me so far
back that and I had a disc injury in my
back and it my vertebrae pincered my
disc in half and I passed out on stage
in front of 750 people
um I just completely blacked out and and
I I didn't know where I was when I woke
up and um
and I haven't been back on stage since
and that was 2002 and I've always wanted
to go back on stage but you know you
when you and then then which was the
same year that the two towers came out
actually and then the kind of I started
getting involved in in many more film
projects but I love theater and I and in
a world where you know it's funny enough
I was talking to Tony about this at
lunchtime today in a world where AI is
going to become a huge part of
Storytelling
um where you know where analog feels
like it's almost a safe place we were
both saying Tony and I were both saying
he's back to the theater for me you know
because because it's going to be a very
interesting next couple of decades in
terms of where creativity goes um anyway
sorry this wasn't a short answer but it
was a difficult question
uh I believe we're we're really close to
the end so who yeah exactly do you see
that the whole um so let's do one last
thing do you want to go down here to
someone
from Narita
hey um first I just just want to say
that the last episode one way out was
one of the First episodes where I
stopped what I was doing tears in my
eyes you know hair up on my arms just I
was so enraptured so Bravo to everybody
who worked on it you guys were amazing
but my question is this is your rallying
cry this is your let's get everybody out
and get them out
um did you listen to any popular
speeches like you know Bill Pullman
Independence Day Aragorn return to the
king to kind of get you you know into
that
[Applause]
oh I need to spend more time with ego
you know it's just like
no
I I definitely kind of tried to work it
out for myself you know I mean I hear
what you're saying
um but
um but no no it was uh it was it was I I
had to find Kino's version of of of
trying to find that speech you know so
so but I mean obviously there are
incredible inspiring inciting speeches
which which we we all know but but not
in this case I was going to say ladies
and gentlemen on that note I would
really appreciate it if you would give
these people a round of applause
and and
also uh if you were on this thing called
social media and you enjoy and or don't
be afraid to keep on saying that uh I
really really really say thank you for
doing this and a huge thank you to
Disney for letting us screen these
episodes yeah it's a huge thing for real
thank you for having us and thank you
Steve amazing thank you Steve thank you
so much
thank you